it is a tremendous honor to come and
have the chance to do this not many
people get the chance to come and talk
to this group and I'm certain that
you'll have some great questions for me
later as we've heard bps along links
with Stanford going back very many years
and there one or two people on the
faculty here who probably know more
about BP than I do in particular John
Roberts down at the front who's written
I suspect more case studies on BP than
any other practicing expert this is an
interesting time to be in business it's
it's interesting because of course there
is a big anti business sentiment out
there at the moment it started with the
the chaos in the financial markets but
but it spread and there is a big debate
going on in the world about the role of
business and the importance of business
and where the right balance is struck
between business and government and
they're clear we're clearly living in
difficult times in many many dimensions
I was struck by some data I saw recently
that across the world two-thirds of the
public nel trust business significantly
less than they did a year ago so I have
to say I'm an optimist I think you can
see beyond today's headlines and I'll
share some reasons for my optimism a bit
later on of course it's interesting how
do you define optimism in the spring of
2009 and the most interesting definition
of optimism I've heard so far is an
investment banker on a Sunday evening
ironing five shirts
so I am undoubtedly a subscriber to the
five shirt school of optimism I do also
think that this is an important moment
for business it's an important moment
for good business to stand tall and
speak up because there is no doubt we
need the entrepreneurial spirit of
business to lift countries across the
world out of recession I thought I could
do three things today and I'll try and
do it in 25 or 30 minutes I thought I
talked a little bit which is something I
don't normally do at all a little bit
about me and my experiences of
leadership and just by a way of offering
you some things that have worked for me
I'm not a believer in books on
leadership I don't think I've ever read
a book on leadership my you know for me
leadership is about developing and
encouraging the development of young men
and women to figure out their own way of
doing it but I thought I'd share with
you some things that have worked for me
and maybe one or two of them might work
for you I then thought it'd be
interesting to spend a little while
talking about some of the challenges
that we had at BP over the last few
years you know we had an interesting
period which caused us to really sit
back and take stock about what we were
doing as a company and how we were
trying to slow do things and then
providing time permits I thought I'd
talk a little bit about the challenges
of the energy industry and I'm sure
they'll be one or two people will be
very interested in my perspective on
that as we go forward so I'm gonna start
with some things that are work for me
and that I've got sort of four things
here that have been helpful as I've
developed my career the first thing is
that the notion of following your heart
I don't believe that you can be
successful in life unless you're
absolutely passionate about it and I
once heard someone say that if you live
each day as your last someday you'll be
right seems true
I sort of translated that into if today
was my last day am i doing what I want
to be doing and if the answer to that is
no too often then you should change what
you're doing so my sort of first lesson
in life is about you know be passionate
about what it is you're doing and for me
the passion was geology you heard that I
joined B peers of geology so I'm not
quite sure how I got into geology
originally I can't remember but I became
passionate about it and I joined BP and
for eight or nine years I had a
fantastic time I was doing geology in
the Arctic Circle of Alaska and Canada I
was doing fieldwork in the jungles of
South America the Highlands of Papua New
Guinea the deserts of North Africa
Central Asia and China and you know it
was wonderful well I was sort of it was
it was all I ever wanted to be so
passion about what you do I think
alongside that goes you know you have to
work hard or what it whatever it is I
saw some research recently that said you
can only become really good at something
if you've invested at least 10,000 hours
of effort if you actually do the math
that's quite a lot of effort so be
passionate about what it is you want to
do and invest the time to do it really
well
my second sort of lesson is be
persistent and you know nothing comes
easy and we will have these middle
stories but my sort of lesson of
persistency was when I finished my
undergraduate degree I asked and I
applied to BP and they rejected me
so I thought well you know interesting
I'll see if I can figure out another way
in here so I went off and did a PhD and
the second time around I got offers from
lots of oil and gas companies and I sort
of turned the negotiation around they
were negotiating to attract me rather
than me trying to negotiate to attract
them so be persistent um the third
little lesson is about taking risks and
I don't buy this I don't mean bet the
bank don't take out massively unhedged
positions are going to some CDO but but
I do mean take some risks in what it is
you're doing and again
a little personal story so I've been a
geologist for eight or nine years all I
really wanted to do and I was asked if
I'd like to become the executive
assistant to the then chief executive
this was back in 1990 1991 and this was
a new role at BP no one had a clue what
an executive assistant was and I said to
Mike then Lyme manager you know what do
you think about this and he said problem
do that far to risk you know what do you
want to do that for glorified personal
assistant carrying papers around you
know stick you know stick with it you
know four or five years you can get my
job and then you know who knows you may
have be the chief geologist its position
we don't have anymore so so I sort of
thought about it and I thought well you
know nothing ventured nothing gained
and I accepted the role and it opened my
eyes the world of business at that time
I knew nothing about business I
certainly didn't know my way around a
balance sheet I didn't know some of the
very basics of cash flow you know what
what I knew about business at that point
you could put on a very small postage
stamp
so um take risks and a few years ago
someone gave me a little plaque that I
have on my desk which says if you knew
you could not fail
what would you try and that seems to me
to be a great way to think about the
idea of taking some risk in your
personal development be it career or
otherwise so that's the third thing and
the fourth middle principle that's
worked well for me is and I think this
is really important as you go up an
organization doesn't matter what sort of
organization it is it's the idea that
you you remain connected you stay down
to earth and I've had a number of
experiences that have really brought
that home to me they're the one that was
probably the most profound was in
Venezuela in in the mid 90s I was a
relatively young manager running at bps
operations in Venezuela and we had a
young man was killed in
of conducting one of our operations and
I went to the funeral and at the end of
the funeral the mother his mother came
up to me beat me on my chest and said
why did you let it happen to him
why did you let it happen and that was a
real wake-up to me that you know if you
lead an organization you have a duty of
care for everyone in it it's a fact and
the big and the you know bigger the
organization the more people you're
taking care of and it has influenced
enormous Lee my view about safety in our
operations BP has many operations and
some of them are very dangerous but it
also made me realize you know how
important it is to recognize that you
have a duty of care for people and in
that that same spirit someone who I have
a lot of respect for taught me a lot
about operational safety said that you
know you need to recognize as a leader
when you visit somewhere in your
organization it is a reflection of you
what you see is what you do so stay down
to earth and connected and that and the
sort of final piece in that is again
experiences in Latin America I spent
almost seven years in Colombia and
Venezuela and when I went down to
Colombia I was this sort of bright young
thing thought I knew everything and you
know had sort could articulate with
great clarity intellectually what it was
people needed to do and it took me a
couple of years to realize that
connecting with people with this is only
half of it you have to connect with this
connecting with your heart and I learnt
a lot in Venezuela in terms of
connecting people and I'm grabbing them
grabbing their heart and getting if you
want people to follow you you need to
connect that with their hearts as well
as their heads what one of the things
that I think all of us in big
corporations need to remember that
for many of us through our careers we
sort of turned up at the front door and
I know I did this
I saw the left-half a Tony Hayward at
the front door and I walked in put my
corporate suit on and was sort of you
know mr. corporate VP I think it was
only after my experience in in Latin
America but I actually realized one of
the most powerful things you can do is
bring all of yourself into the office so
rather than leave half of me at the
front door take all of myself in and let
people see the real wheat you the good
and the bad
so for middle things that have been
helpful to me in in in my career today
follow your heart be passionate about
what you do be persistent
life isn't always easy be prepared to
take some personal risk and stay down to
earth and connected and I think that the
last point is particularly true as you
assume larger and larger leadership
roles so that's some thoughts on you
know what's worked let me turn now to
say a few things about the last few
years at BP which have been an
interesting few years for those of us
everyone in BP actually not just those
at the top but everyone in BP and and so
sort of put it in context I just have to
say a few things about history BP until
the late 90s BP was a relatively small
regional oil and gas company it was
described as a seventh sister but
actually it had two big assets it had a
the North Sea oil fields and it had the
Alaskan oil fields and not very much
else and in an extraordinary period
between 99 and 2003 we put together our
whole series of mergers and acquisitions
under the leadership of my predecessor
John Brown I was very much involved in
it but it was undoubtedly John that
career
created the drive to do this such that
by 2003 we had created BP in pretty well
its current form one of the largest
integrated oil and gas companies energy
companies in the world a so-called super
major I will debate with
Josh whether with second or third but
you know depend on what metric you know
we're sort of we're sort of equal second
really with these operations everywhere
and then we sort of catastrophe struck
and in the space of several years we had
a whole series of real disasters
actually we blew up a refinery in Texas
City and killed fifteen people our
flagship project called thunderhorse
almost ended up on the seabed in 6,000
feet of water in the Gulf of Mexico we
had a major major oil spill in Alaska we
were found guilty by the Department of
Justice for a trading manipulation in
the natural gas markets of the US and
our financial performance over that time
period was appalling
we underperformed our major competitors
by anywhere between 30 to 50 percent and
at the end of that two year period so
this is sort of in the early spring of
2007 the sort of general view in the
world was this was either analysts or
the news meter two years to fix it
otherwise someone's going to come along
and put them out of their misery and so
it was with that that I was given the
job of being the CEO at BP interesting
place to start life it's not I probably
would have chosen however I know you
know it's the first thing I would say is
I think when you you know when you're
faced with a situation like that the
only thing you can do is to confront it
head-on now that's probably harder to do
as an insider than someone coming in
from the outside frankly but I assembled
a new team partly in fact in large part
from people within the company with one
or two people that we brought in from
the outside and we underwent a really
critical self-assessment actually which
is you know quite difficult to do but it
was it was clearly absolutely necessary
so what was their diagnosis well we
diagnose in no particular order that the
the following a company that was too
top-down too directive not and not good
at listening
and the what used to be a little joke
about you know good news traveled
instantly and bad news didn't travel at
all we fail to recognize for an
operating company we had too many people
that did not understand what it took to
run operations we had too many shallow
generalists people who knew a lot about
not very much but not a lot about
specific areas we had too many people
that were working to save the world we'd
sort of lost track of the fact that our
primary purpose in life is to create
value for our shareholders how you do
that you need to take care of the world
but our primary purpose in life was not
to save the world we had an extra
created an extraordinary matter
complexity as we put these companies
together we created this very complex
matrix organization and one of the only
pieces of external input we got at the
time was I asked to consult them to come
and hold up a mirror to be Peter I just
said I don't want any answers about what
we should do but I would like a
outside-in perspective of what you see
and they came back after a couple of
months and said you know we've got some
interesting news we think I said oh
really what's that we think you've set a
new benchmark in fact we know you set a
new benchmark and I said really yes they
said you are the most complex company
we've ever come across and they had mats
they had maps 10,000 organisational
interfaces in the BP of 2007 and for a
company that has a hundred thousand
employees that's pretty impressive
so a lot of complexity and we were we
were bedeviled which happens to many
corporations from time to time too much
analysis not enough decision making and
I just need to give him my mobile phone
to someone Thanks so um fairly critical
self evaluation and we sort of then sat
down as a team not with any external
help to figure out what we're going to
do about it and we did a few simple
things we created something called
which we referred to as a forward agenda
which was a focus on safe reliable
operations people having the right
people with the right skills in the
right place and if you take the top 650
people of BP at that time we reduced
that number by 25% and we changed out
50% of them big change and the third
piece of the forward agenda was about
performance which was about restoring
revenues were missing and reducing
complexity and when we did some fairly
conventional things that to reduce
complexity in terms of organization
which you know is not nothing very
magical but but necessary
I think this second thing so forward
agenda but the second thing that we did
was we'd lost track of the competition
and we reinstated very rigorous
competitive benchmarking across the
company the most profound level it will
the most rudimentary level Ashley it was
looking at our performance as a company
against principled competitor shell and
in the second quarter of 2007 on an
annualized basis we had a gap of eight
billion dollars relative to shell in
terms of what we should have been
generating from our asset base versus
what they were and we use that as a
burning platform you know I use that as
the rallying cry behind this big change
that we we we have subsequently been
driving through through BP so the second
piece of this was about recognized the
competitive dynamics that the third
thing was to do with leadership and the
culture of the company and at that time
it turned out we had 36 live and
operating leadership models at various
parts of BP not surprising we assembled
all these companies from all over the
place and they all had their different
bits of heritage so my my team spent
three or four months without any
consultants without any external help
talking about the company that we wanted
the culture that we wanted and the
leadership framework that we called it
which would begin to enable that sort of
culture and it was pretty simple you
know everyone does this sort of stuff
from time to time I'm not arguing that
it's any great sort of revolutionary
insight this but it was an important
thing for us at that time to create a
coherent way of talking about what we
thought was important in leadership at
BP the first one was this idea of
recognizing skills and professional
capability and competence we had lost
that so we had too far as I said far too
many generalists and not enough deep
specialists the second thing was to
recognize how important is to energize
and motivate people sounds pretty
straightforward but you know a lot of
our leadership had lost focus of that
the third piece of it was around
decision-making taking decisions too
much introspection too much debate not
enough people taking decisions and
getting on and the fourth piece of it
was delivering results so a new
leadership framework which was to begin
to enable the culture that we wanted to
see and you know leadership frameworks
mean different things to different folks
what I'm very certain about is that a
culture of an organization is shaped by
the leaders in it people do what leaders
do that that's been proven time and time
again so this was about beginning to
change the culture of BP we never talked
about it like that we never used the
word cultural change or anything like
that but that's what we were doing and
we were creating the leadership basis on
which on which that would happen and
we're only in that journey it's probably
a three to five year journey with the
people who work in the offices and it's
probably a five plus year journey with
the people who work out on the
facilities what was my role in all of
that well it was to keep it focused
to create clarity for people I think the
most important act of leadership any of
us do is to create clarity for folk to
create clarity from ambiguity to be
consistent I have got so bored with
saying safety people and performance but
I'm determined that I'm not going to say
anything else
and finally and the most important thing
it's the most important thing I do now
is to encourage and motivate folk I mean
I think of myself as bp's highest-paid
cheerleader what i do is go out and
encourage and motivate people that's
what i do i don't actually take big
decisions i see about their encouraging
and motivating people um is it working
well I would say we're making progress
we're not there yet we've closed the
financial gap so eight billion dollars
in the second quarter of 2007 has become
no gap at all in the second quarter of
2009 so that's what we've beaten the
market throughout the last four quarters
and there is a lot of momentum in the
company in terms of rising revenues and
falling costs so there's a lot of
momentum but it's clear that to create
this sort of company that we now want to
create which will be sustainable we have
more work still to do so that's a little
bit about BP now I think I've still got
time to say a a few words about the
world's energy future before I find out
what all of you want to grill me about
so I think I should begin this by saying
as far as I'm concerned the future has
not been canceled it has been delayed by
a year or two but it has definitely not
been canceled the world will recover
growth will resume and when it does
energy demand will continue to rise
inexorably and almost projections the
world will need 40 percent more energy
in 2030 which is not very long away than
it does today that is driven by two
things it's driven firstly by population
growth in the time that I've been on the
planet
the population has doubled from 3
billion to 6 billion and by the time
most of the people in this room are my
age another 3 billion people will be on
the planet so the first thing is this
extraordinary population growth the
second one is the industrialization that
is taking place in the developing world
at a scale that the world has never
before seen in the next decade just in
the next decade 500 million people are
going to make the transition from an a
rural way of life to an urban one and
that brings tremendous challenges and I
thought I could tell you a little story
that's a deeply personal one but sort of
captures it so 20 odd years ago I was a
young geologist in Beijing and at the
time you weren't allowed to drive a car
so I had a driver young guy he just got
married had his first child he was
living with his parents in a two-room
futon and their energy consumption was
to kerosene lamps and a small coal
brassiere for four people three adults
and a four adults and a child last
summer I took my family out to the
Olympics its first on my wife had been
back for 20 years and obviously the
first time the kids had been I've been
there cuz we didn't have kids when we
were there before and the same man is
working as a driver for BP so that's the
most people that's an important piece of
this story same job same person after a
couple of weeks coming to the end of the
trip he said come and see my new
apartment so we Julie went round to see
his new apartment we get out the car a
25-story tower block their apartments on
the 18th floor there's underground car
parking for his Chinese built automobile
we got out at the 18th floor and there
is a electric scooter his wife's
electric scooter is in the hallway we go
into the apartment it's a three bedroom
apartment underfloor heating air
conditioning and humidifying for the
summer
one of these enormous american-style I
call them fridge freezer things though
you know we don't get in the UK but you
guys have all got that he's gonna
Norma's great things you can walk in in
the on the wall of the kitchen there's a
small flat screen TV on the wall of the
lounge there's an enormous flat-screen
TV and on each one of the three bedrooms
as a flat-screen TV so he's got more
flat-screen TVs than I have and that's
true and you know that was it and I sort
of looked at this and I you know I I
went back 20 years
like to what had happened and it's an
extraordinary story it's an
extraordinary story of course of what
China has achieved China has done that
to 350 million people now that's great
the course the the problem is there are
another 800 million to go and if you
think about his energy consumption or
his family's energy consumption over
that time period
a cold brassiere and to kerosene lamps
to aircon you know AC humidifying
flat-screen TVs I'm certain a half a
dozen laptops I didn't see them but I'm
certain they were there you know so the
world is going to continue to demand
ever-increasing amounts of energy and
and the energy industry has a hell of a
task to provide it most estimates
suggests that we're going to have to
invest 26 trillion dollars between now
and 2030 to provide the energy that the
world needs you do the math that's more
than the trillion dollars a year
and it's interesting to put that in the
context of the commitment by the new
president in the u.s. to invest 150
billion dollars in alternative energy
over 10 years it just puts it in context
the good news is that we do have the
natural human and financial resources to
provide the world with enough energy and
do it in a sustainable way the
challenges today are not below ground
they're above ground they're not
geological they're human and it's
creating alignment around what the right
approaches that
is the big challenge it's fair to say
that not everyone is agreed on how to on
the one hand to create the energy the
world needs on the other hand do it in a
sustainable way but as I've said I I am
a five shirts on a Sunday night optimist
and I I think increasingly principled
stakeholders are coming to a consensus
and a consensus probably looked
something like this
it recognizes that for this to happen
you need stable and trap a stable and
transparent business environment because
it is business that's going to make this
investment it's not government its
business the second is that free and
open energy markets are the best way of
getting the resources allocated in the
right way the third is that we need to
be honest about the future of
hydrocarbons we can't deny that the
future is only about alternative energy
we can't pretend that it is only about
alternative energy
hydrocarbons represent 80% of the
world's energy today and by everyone's
projections by 2050 they will still be
the majority and just another little
point of data today today to create the
same unit of energy you invest a dollar
in oil and gas and you need to invest
five dollars in alternative energy have
reached across the portfolio that's the
energy efficiency equation that we have
today so the final point I would say is
that the world is coming together around
the need for an economy-wide carbon
price to promote energy efficiency and
to support alternative energy
developments for a long time BP has
argued that the right way to do this is
through a cap-and-trade mechanism my
expectation is that the US will
implement a cap-and-trade mechanism
probably in the course of next year if
not then by 2011 that will be a defining
moment for the world because there's no
doubt that once the u.s. crosses the
Rubicon others will follow and I was
with a couple of the Chinese Vice
premiers on Sunday evening actually in
London and we were talking about it and
it's very clear when the u.s. moves
China will follow they haven't quite
figured out what they're going to do but
they are definitely will be evolving
their position so just to conclude um as
you as you've heard me say I am an
optimist I believe absolutely in the
power of technology and innovation and
it is through those two things and human
ingenuity and cooperation that we have
cracked the world's problems in the past
and that's what I expect will happen
this time it is undoubtedly one of the
world's biggest challenges probably the
biggest challenge today and will be for
the next 20 or 30 years how do you on
the one hand provide energy that is safe
and affordable for continued economic
development and on the other hand do it
in a sustainable way that preserves the
environment for future generations and I
have to say it's that challenge that
gets me up in the morning that's a good
place to stop let me see what you'd like
to talk about
someone damn in front a you to just have
to wait for a mic I think people want a
high if you were to assess yourself as a
leader what are two things you're really
good at and what are two things that you
really need to improve upon great this
is a great question so the two things
that I really need to improve on are
listening better and harder and being
less impetuous and less prone to take
rapid decisions I think things that I'm
good at I am good at creating clarity
for people and I'm good at engaging with
people you know as I walk around the
refinery's I'm I can engage with the
folk running the refineries but my
weaknesses are undoubtedly needs to
listen more and which is interesting
given what I said about VP right and and
you know be less prone to take decisions
sometimes it's not a good idea to take a
quick decision sometimes it is but
sometimes isn't yeah so last quarter we
had had the CEO of ExxonMobil here and
he was quite friend Rick's yes exactly
and he actually they show that a long
time he made a very well to me was at
least was a surprising call for a carbon
tax the view that is preferable to cap
and trade or other carbon credit
transfer schemes because it would be
more transparent and simpler so the
question is you said that was bp's view
it's a cap-and-trade is the way you're
looking is that your own personal view
do you think there should be more
alignment within the oil industry itself
to solve this problem because I wanna
know as well do you have projects
princes that you're holding up because
of the uncertainty around
how is carbon gonna be priced well I
think I mean the first thing I'd say is
the most important thing is to put a
price on carbon because until that is
done there is no certainty about the
benefits are otherwise of alternative
energy and the costs through the carbons
they emit of existing sources of energy
I think my ration my personal view and
and actually the view and indeed the
view of BP is that cap-and-trade is best
because what we're looking for is
environmental certainty we're not
looking for an extra source of revenue
now you know the current administration
clearly sees this as an opportunity to
raise additional revenue but this is
about providing environmental certainty
and if you put a carbon tax on it gives
you no environmental certainty tells you
nothing about what's going to happen to
emissions tells you energy is going to
be more expensive but it will tell you
nothing about you know there's no no
reason to believe with the carbon tax
that people will use less energy whereas
if you have an absolute cap on emissions
and the cap comes down over time then
you know you know you have a mechanism
that's solving the problem of the moment
which is how do we get emissions down so
that is the rationale for believing a
cap-and-trade mechanism is the best way
of doing it I think a secondary argument
may be less important is if you use a
carbon tax it means that a government
somewhere has got to decide what is the
best way to allocate resources you know
they've got to say we're going to tax
this by this much and that by that much
whereas if you have a cap-and-trade
mechanism and the market is working then
the resources will go be distributed in
the most efficient way but I think the
big point is this thing of about
environmental certainty because that's I
see what we need and Rex and I debated
this long and hard
I first convinced him that he's failed
to convince me yes given the ongoing
role that you've received for
hydrocarbons in the economy could you
talk a little bit about the role of
carbon sequestration technologies what
he's doing to advance those or other
carbon mitigation strategies that you
have great a great question
I think I think without sounding
arrogant I can reasonably say that BP
has probably got the two leading
commercial scale carbon capture and
sequestration projects in the world
today one of them is in Abu Dhabi and
the second one is here in California
Bakersville where we are looking in the
case of Bakersville to take petroleum
coke to burn it to separate the gas into
hydrogen to run through some big
turbines and to sequester the co2 in
some old oil fields and the co2 will
actually help increase the recovery from
the old oil field the technology is all
proven in the component parts so we know
how to build a turbine to run hydrogen
we know how to build a gasifier to
separate the gas and create co2 and and
the hydrogen stream and the oil industry
has been using co2 to increase recovery
for 30 or 40 years so all of the pieces
are known no one has put put it together
at scale and the big challenge is the
cost so it just so happens that I spent
an hour this morning reviewing this
project before I came down here so it's
all fresh but the fact is that the fully
built up costs of what would be a 400
megawatt power plant is three billion
dollars if you just went out and built a
gas-fired power plant to the same scale
the cost would be about eight hundred
million dollars so there is an enormous
incremental cost and if you do the maths
then the cost of co2 sequestered is
around one hundred and twenty five
hundred thirty dollars a ton so the
problem today is the technology exists
but it's very expensive and you know the
world has to decide whether it's
prepared to pay the cost what does that
translate into in cents per kilowatt
hour Californians today pay twelve cents
a kilowatt hour for their electricity
electricity from this plant will cost 31
or 32 cents a kilowatt hour so it's a
sort of choice right so it would be nice
to say carbon capture and sequestration
is going to come along and save the
world in the next three or four years it
isn't it may be very important in 20 or
so years time but it's not going to be
important as scale in the next 10 years
one at the back you painted one scenario
of your view what the most likely energy
future will look like
including a relatively rapid recovery
energy demand and a sustained role for
fossil fuels through 2050 but on the
other hand the head of research from the
IMF spoke about the potential for a
sustained recession scenario where we
don't see energy demand recovering to
previous levels until around 2014 we
also know that there many clean tech
startups in the Bayer and elsewhere
they're looking to develop breakthroughs
that could significantly change the
trajectory for alternatives Brezza V
fossil fuels over the next few decades
so my question is what are the big
uncertainties out there that you think
could potentially change fundamentally
change your business model and their
scenario for energy more generally that
you presented and how do you think about
mitigating those returning them into
opportunities yeah well I suppose the
idea the way of the most sensible word
mitigation is to be participating in
that world and of course we are we have
arguably the biggest alternative energy
business where in biofuels were in wind
particularly in the u.s. we're in
biofuels in Brazil in Europe and in the
u.s. we're in carbon capture and
sequestration and we're in solar so
we're very cognizant of what is
happening I you know back to the
beginning of your question I hope very
much that we don't have a recession
slash depression for the next four or
five years that will be a very bad
outcome for the for the world what I
would say is irrespective at some point
we will start growing again and the
world's demand for energy is on the
trend that I talked about and I think to
put it in perspective you have to
recognize that at the moment the Chinese
are putting on the ground one 500
megawatt coal-fired power plant a week a
week so the you know believing that we
will see a dramatic breakthrough in the
ten years in terms of the sources of our
energy I think is probably unlikely
it really is it's not ever been the
history of the energy space the
transition from wood to coal took place
over 30 or 40 years the transition from
coal to oil took place over 30 or 40
years their transition from oil to gas
took place over 30 or 40 years we could
be wrong but it's it's not what I think
is very likely the big opportunity and
it is a big opportunity for the next
decade is one of energy efficiency it's
not where the energy comes from it's how
do we use it how do we use it much more
efficiently than we do today and that
you know it that is about all of the
things that people are talking about
it's about buildings of cafe standards
for cars it's everything the amount of
energy per capita used in this society
is extraordinary relative to any other
Society on the planet the amount of
energy per capita used in Europe is
similar you know we there are so many
things that can be done and that is the
big opportunity in the very near term
and it's good to see that today that
agenda has a lot of serious political
support behind it I guess is what I'd
say I think if you look at it's a hell
of a long answer I'm gonna stop soon
but if you look at if you look at sort
of you know a practical way of through
this
let's take Graham transportation the
first thing to do is do fuel efficiency
from today's internal combustion engine
we could double or more the efficiency
of the internal combustion engine you
know we can have cars that do
comfortably 70 miles to the gallon
easily and they'd be perfectly good cars
the next thing in there in that space is
to introduce biofuels there's no doubt
that in the matter of gasoline sales
from oil the peak in history was in 2000
and
seven but we'll never be more gasoline
so in this country not any in the world
but in this country there will never be
more gasoline sold in this country
produced from oil than the wars in 2007
efficiency is going to drive overall
demand down and within that there will
be an increasing wedge of biofuels so
the next thing on ground transportation
is biofuels beyond that it's the world
of hybrids and beyond that it's the
world of electric and batteries that's a
very sensible way of thinking about
ground transportation in the matter of
power it's about how do we diversify the
portfolio how do we bring in more
nuclear how do we drive wind to perhaps
20 percent and how do we take advantage
in this country of the tremendous
domestic gas resource so that you can
paint a very credible way of dealing
with this challenge without invoking or
requiring a major technology
breakthrough but it does require some
joined up thinking and aligned political
will and leadership which I would say
has hitherto been missing but you know
I'm optimistic is emerging quite quickly
at the moment actually
thank you changing tack slowly from
energy you face an incredible backlash
at home from shareholders and your board
as well about your own remuneration so
if you could talk a bit about how that's
affected you personally and how you've
reconciled what you earn with what those
shoulders think yeah I think this is an
interesting moment in some interesting
sign of the times because you know I'm
pretty modestly played by some people
and I think it's what I talked about the
beginning there is an extrordinary
backlash today against against business
and what I've seen as rewards for
failure so and I don't the reason
there's not a simple answer to this what
you know what started in the financial
community has spread to
business more broadly and I think it
will be with us for some time I mean I I
haven't I'd be honest with you I haven't
thought a lot about it in a personal
personal sense but I think in a business
sense in a and dealing with the societal
backlash against business is something
that should concern everyone in business
profoundly at the moment because if it
gets too strong then we will undoubtably
have policies enacted by politicians
because they respond to people who vote
and if people are vote they're saying
that we need to punish business then
business will be punished and of course
it was exactly that sort of policy in
the early thirties that created a
prolonged recession or depression so I
think it's something that is a great
concern I also believe that it's
necessary for us to really acknowledge
where failures occurred I mean it's
clear that some of the some of the
salaries and bonuses have been wholly
inappropriate I would say I think
largely in the financial sector
personally but I probably would say that
would my I'm not a banker it is because
I have to you know I'm obviously knows
some of the guys that do run banks and
last summer's in New York I was chatting
with Jamie Dimon and Lloyd Blankfein and
they just been in front of the
congressional committee and I was saying
you know it's it's great not to be on
the front pages because it's normally
the oil and gas guys who are the bad
guys on the front pages and but for the
time being it won't last forever but for
the time being someone else has
displaced us as being the most popular
people on the planet but I it's a great
question that which I don't have a good
answer in the middle um definitely mr.
Hayward back to the topic of alternative
energy BB's got a growing alternative
energy portfolio and it's probably gonna
play an even greater part in the VP's
future given that how does the company
balance its decision-making you know
with respect to capital allocation and
company resources between its growing
alternative energy business and its
expertise and fossil fuels especially
when it you know comes on to the impact
on the bottom line and conflicts and
profitability when proceeding with
projects yeah that's a good question
I think I thinking around this is has
evolved quite a lot over the last two or
three years because I do think there are
in the alternative energy spaces there
is there are some things that are very
close to our core business for where we
have the inherent skills and
capabilities and should be very
competitive in in those areas and others
where we've got to build new skills so
they are different and it's appropriate
to think about them differently so as I
think about our alternative energy
portfolio biofuels will become it is but
it will become an even greater part of
that core business we are the biggest
blender of biofuels today in the US and
Europe because we're required to by law
we believe that the if you take the
gasoline pool in the u.s. for certainly
biofuels will represent 10% of the
gasoline pool by 2020 and it's
conceivable with the right support and
legislation and a few technology
breakthroughs that are at the point of
happening that it could be twenty
percent so in biofuels it's sort of
where we're actually talking about
should we invest into biofuels or should
we make an incremental investment into a
refinery it's actually quite a
straightforward discussion to take place
because you're trying to create the same
end product in the case of carbon
capture and storage I've talked about
that I mean it clearly is that that is a
business if it ever takes off which you
know today it's not clear that it will
has very strong links to our core TMP
business it's about reservoir management
and now you put co2 in the ground and
manage it that's where most of the value
will probably reside today in that area
what we're trying to do is demonstrate
that you can do it commercially I mean
it's not actually commercial oil because
it requires a lot of support in the
matter of wind we've taken a decision to
only do wind in the US and
I think wind is something that is is 4bp
as a marginal capital allocation process
we've got a big wind
portfolio in the US and we build it out
you know as the sort of funds are
available so it doesn't compete directly
with their other businesses that the one
that's the biggest challenge for us is
this business of solar and how do we
participate in that and you know the
answer is we haven't figured out what
the right way to do it is it's
completely different from our existing
business it is a long-term bet on the
future and it's not right to compare and
the investment in it today with an
investment in EMV so we sort of try and
hold it separately and preserve some
elements of investment into it and that
you know I would say we've not we
haven't actually created the right yet
way of thinking about that business or
the right wave for Beefeater sort of
hold it I just a quick question on the
operational side of things so when he
said there was an oil spill in the last
car and the facilities blew up the Gulf
of Mexico failure how did he deal with
that when you became the CEO so how did
you deal with all the negative press in
financials with one thing but there you
had to react immediately you couldn't
get a study in place for three months
and then respond so one was that the
second thing is more on the alternate
side which is like Chevron as Chevron
Energy Solutions which is working on
efficiency there's B we have something
on an efficiency side like you mentioned
it's one of the most important things
over the next decade yeah on the
efficiency thing we do we drive it
through our existing businesses so all
of our existing businesses are targeted
to continuously improve their efficiency
what we're not doing is providing a
third-party service to others to improve
efficiency because we just don't think
that's what our core skill is because
the you know it's about interfacing with
potentially tens of thousands of people
it's not what we do but we within each
one of our big principle business lines
they have very clear efficiency targets
in terms of energy efficiency in terms
of your first question which is a very
good question I think you know
the first thing you have to do is be
absolutely transparent and open about
what has gone on and recognize it
and not sort of be in denial so the
first thing is you know acknowledgement
open and transparent acknowledgement of
the issues and then the second thing of
course is to have a clear plan designed
to go and Remy did them and I talked a
little bit about some of the things that
we've done I didn't have time to talk in
detail about everything but one of the
things in an operational sense that
we've introduced is a common operating
management system what one of the issues
that those events uncovered was that BP
operated two different standards all
over the world not surprising it had
come from many different companies but
we had not put in place a common way of
operating so if you went to a refinery
in Texas he could have been you know
didn't know no indication it was from BP
went to a an offshore facility which is
part of that Macklowe heritage no
indication it was sort of BP so what
we've done is put in place an operating
management system that is designed to
ensure that every one of bps operating
facilities across the world looks and
feels the same so you walk onto it you
know it's a BP site the operating
standards are bps operating standards
they're a consistently high level so you
know there's a lot of things beneath
that but that's one of the big things
that and that won't happen overnight but
with sort of a couple years into it now
by the end of this year we'll have
probably 75 80 percent of our operations
running on that system and aligned with
that we have built the ability to
deliver a lot of capability to our
operational staff it turned out we
hadn't been investing enough in
everything - our people didn't have
enough skills and capabilities in their
operations so we've put in place a big
program I won't tell you where it is one
or two people on the front right won't
be very they will aware of it
but it's at one of your competing one of
the competing universities but it is
designed to create real operating
capability in the company in a way that
we didn't have and it's part of this you
know really recognizing that BP makes
its money by someone somewhere every day
putting on boots coveralls a hard hat
and glasses and going out and turning
valves that's how we make our money and
we'd sort of lost track of that may be a
good place on which to finish